well if my daughter were to see this I
would hope that she's proud of me that
she can see that her mother did care
about something and that I that it's
worth fighting for - my future president
my name is and joram uterus but most
people call me Andy I'm a proud single
mother of a beautiful two-year-old her
name is Catalina my first job is being a
single mom it's obviously not a choice
but it definitely has its rewards when
I'm not busy raising my daughter I'm
working at McDonald's at 116 oohing I
like it a lot because of the
appreciation I'm showing for my
customers I get up early for work every
day and I stretch my paycheck to make
ends meet I only make $10.50 an hour
that Chicago's current minimum wage I
worry about paying for groceries clothes
and my daughter's medical bills she was
born prematurely because I can't afford
most things sometimes I have to accept
hand-me-down clothes for Catalina I also
have to cancel doctor appointments and
sometimes take leftover food from family
and friends recently I qualify for food
stamps which is a slight improvement but
I shouldn't have to rely on government
assistance to get by the kind of life I
live takes a toll on my daughter at me
it's hard but I try my best to make sure
it got the Leena's happy and that makes
me happy too
as a future president you should be
concerned about what happens to your
working-class people we serve fast
convenient meals for families we keep
the city streets clean and we help front
airports I fight for 15 and Union rates
and I will continue to do so to make
sure every worker can live with dignity
and respect we've already won raises 420
million workers I hope that you would
join us in protecting the American dream
no one in this country should have to
work for less than $50 an hour or
without the rights of being in a union
as our president we need you to raise
pay and tear down the barriers to
opportunity my daughter's life is
counting on you
sincerely interim you got pnina's mom